chers habitants de lille marcq en
baroeul bondues mouvaux à tourcoing je
suis nicolas papinashvili avocat au
barreau de lille et adjoint au maire de
marcq en baroeul
arrivé en france à l'âge de 10 ans j'ai
grandi dans l'aisne avant de poursuivre
mes études à lille mon histoire
personnelle celle de ma famille est le
fondement de ma reconnaissance envers la
france aujourd'hui je veux lui rendre
tout ce qu'elle m'a donné depuis mon
plus jeune âge je me suis engagé pour
aider et représenter les autres c'est ce
qui m'a amené au métier d'avocat que
j'exerce avec passion depuis plus de dix
ans au barreau de lille c'est aussi tout
naturellement que je me suis engagé dans
la vie publique dès l'âge de 17 ans
depuis 2014 je m'investis à marcq en
baroeul d'abord comme conseiller
municipal puis adjoint au maire en
charge du développement économique dans
l'équipe de bernard gérard chaque jour
je m'attache à défendre et porter la
voix de nos entreprises commerçants
artisans et agriculteurs de ces femmes
et ces hommes qui font la fierté de
notre territoire
aujourd'hui je veux aller plus loin dans
mon engagement je crois en la grandeur
de la france qui est un modèle dans le
monde je crois à la valeur travail qui a
perdu de son sens au mérite qui permet à
chacun de réussir je crois en la
proximité que je veux incarner dans
toutes ses dimensions en renforçant les
circuits courts en oeuvrant à la
transition écologique et en étant proche
de vous à chaque instant ceux qui me
connaissent savent que je suis quelqu'un
d'entier avec ses qualités et ses
défauts mais qui ne renonce jamais c'est
pour toutes ces raisons que je suis
candidat aux élections législatives de
juin prochain pour devenir votre député
dans les prochains jours avec mon équipe
je viendrai à votre rencontre pour
partager mon projet et vous assurer de
ma détermination à vous servir
[Musique]